foreign
I grew up Los Angeles
and then a mom moved us out to San
Gabriel Valley which is like El Monte I
was the only black guy in El Monte
how would you describe your childhood uh
um disciplined and sneaky you know
because Mom was so disciplined we had to
sneak off and be dumb so you know pretty
much
do typical kid stuff oh yeah my mother's
an attorney at the time so you know um
she's actually a judge on television now
she's been on there for quite a while
and um here would take us out of town
and out of country and stuff as we were
young and stuff done different trips and
stuff and come by time I got 14 15 I
stopped going on the trips because the
last time the trip which you took of was
Mardi Gras in Louisiana but she would
let us go party it's like we're right
there on Bourbon Street big old crowd
going down butt naked titties everywhere
and she wouldn't let us go downstairs
and kick it and um I figured like I
could get more [ __ ] at home while she
was out of town truck stop started
denying the trips ditch parties and
stuff like that how far did you go to
school I went to college for just a
couple years they did and what kind of
jobs have you had
um security
warehouse work
data entry type real good spell real
good read real good
clerical work telemarketing
but it pretty much just mostly security
you'll go down to Figueroa Street and
pick up girls sometimes yeah when
they're available to be picked up
oh yeah I know I know tell me what would
drive what brings you down there
um
the butt naked display
that's that's the first part
because a lot of times they won't mess
with black guys
that's right they either especially guys
black guys drive a truck like mine with
rims on them they think I'm a 10 pimp so
instantly I'm I'm a No-No
and then um
and then they're they're told not to
speak to other black to other black men
because then you're in violation yeah
yeah it makes it hard I get the ones
that are uh pretty much
off the line as far as um the pimp thing
you know I mean the young fine ones I
don't get too often I get the regular
ones that's been in there a while you
know what I'm saying they didn't did
that already and now they Renegade they
doing their own thing and they're
motivated by drugs you know what I'm
saying so the out there just trying to
get money to the next high so I catch
pretty much them those are the ones that
I pretty much get most of the time
and you've been doing this for how long
oh
at least 15 years
you've been married before I've been
married
legally separated in 2010
my phone ruined my marriage is that what
happened yeah remember back when they
had the little slide phones it had the
little keyboard up underneath it and if
you touched it by accident it would dial
the last person that was dialed that it
dialed in in one morning I was in this
program
drug program in um Saturday morning and
I'd snuck out out the program to go see
this girl a few blocks away and we were
doing it and stuff so I was telling the
guys right before a meeting that morning
and I got them all crowded around like
yeah man baby it was this maybe it was
that in my phone dialed my wife's job
and she heard this she didn't hear it to
Monday but this is a Saturday morning it
recorded the whole thing so when I got
home that week the following weekend all
my stuff was moved out the living room
I'm out the bedroom my drawer my dress
was sitting outside and I had to and I
had to go to the den
and never went back
I was in Denver about three years and
then my mom like get out of there it's
overweight man don't be sitting around
there acting like a dependent you know
what I'm saying so I grew up at 84 9 50
and um been on my own ever since I think
I grew up at 50 years old
are there some advantages to these kind
of relationships with these girls on the
street yeah um yeah if you get one that
that that that you really get along with
you you know I mean you guys clicking
one that fit you know what I'm saying
and um
and uh you start getting feelings for
these girls and stuff and you got to
remember that this is what she does you
know what I'm saying tomorrow she'll be
making the same sounds she made with you
with somebody else it's all the act for
the most part you know what I'm saying
and um start getting feelings and stuff
and you forget that this is this is how
it works you know what I'm saying she
ain't made no promises to you you start
getting possessive and you know you know
what I mean and jealous and all that
sort of type of junk
I got one the one that's with me now is
the one I was talking about I haven't
seen her in
two weeks she's been locked down with
some other cat and some other cat I've
seen her in passing a couple of times
but she didn't have time for me I just
happened to luck up on her by accident
in fact um
the last time we're supposed to get
together she was uh
I was down on King and Western
seeing a friend and she calls me she
didn't have anywhere to go she was on
the Vermont bus going north she's almost
at Wilshire
and I said well
um I got barely got in mind I just made
some money she goes get you see if you
can get a room over there it's a hundred
dollar room I got 85 bucks so I found a
few more dollars in there and hopefully
that they had a room available and they
did and I get the room she's supposed to
jump off the bus get back on the bus and
come back down to King and I'm gonna
pick her up on my motorcycle
well I tracked the buses from this is a
12 midnight that we have this
conversation the first bus come no she's
not on it second bus coming I'm going
back and forth because it's like it's
running like every hour at this point by
4 30 in the morning I've tracked four
buses and she's not on any of them I
can't call her she has no phone and um I
ain't got a room for nothing and now
it's too late to go get another girl
because it's four in the morning they're
all gone for the night so I was hot and
I was broke now I spent all my money for
nothing and I haven't seen her I didn't
even want to talk to her she tried to
talk to me um a couple of times I said I
ain't got nothing to say to say to you
you know what I'm saying
but then again she yesterday she just
happened to pop up and be by herself and
I was waiting on another girl to show up
another one exactly
he's pissed at me because uh
she uh
because I wasn't there when she showed
up however uh I made plans with her at
uh 1 30.
it's uh five o'clock now 1 30 she says
when she finishes her hair bald head
[ __ ] ain't got no hair you know what
I'm saying in an hour she's supposed to
meet me two hours later I'm sitting in
the car waiting on her and uh she's at
she's on Florence and Hooper it's a just
a little tap tap uh
Casino there she think I don't know that
oh my floor is an Uber had to run and
stop and do something you know I'm
saying I'm like you're not the tap tap
you know what I'm saying she goes well
so thank you for wasting my time and um
maybe I'll see you some other time and I
hit a corner and next thing and I get a
call I'm on the way to see you right now
where are you so I'll be over on Western
Manchester in a few minutes I'm on the
way because I take about 20 minutes to
get there she's not there well I'm at
the gas station on Florence and Western
now we're we're coming you know what I'm
saying and that's when old girl pops up
and I take off with her I figure she did
me like that let me give her a taste of
her own medicine and she's been cussing
me out ever since in fact she just text
me again talking about I'm an
incompetent buffoon and all this those
type of stuff and you know my I had a
family emergency my sister and her
daughter were kidnapped and she sent me
some pictures from some random people
and how do you feel now you fat [ __ ]
and this this and that she's calling me
and I go knock it off I know where you
was at I ain't new to this [ __ ] you know
treat people the way you want to be
treated and you won't have to be treated
the [ __ ] that way you treated me I
thought I'd give you a bar to taste your
own medicine you started it you know so
I let her have it what else you want to
do fight cause I do it's my last line to
it she ain't said nothing now the
addiction comes first okay and they're
all about money it's all about the money
and I had the money for her this one I
don't need no money
it was an easy thing to figure out but I
was I haven't I was um
had to deal with her because the other
one hadn't been available
and then there she was at my truck while
I'm waiting on this one as we were
pulling out I see another one pulling up
I was gone [ __ ] her man
you got me sitting around you got the
tap tap and I'm sitting here waiting on
you
but you got emergency what have you
learned about women from these
interactions with these girls whatever
learned uh don't put your uh heart into
them
uh don't trust them
unless you work up over before but then
even then you better not trust them
because you can always get get high
because that's what they're I mean
they're Hustlers bottom line you got to
remember that man ain't nothing special
about you you know what I'm saying
you're gonna be a trick be a trick you
know what I'm saying and I promise and I
probably myself not being a trick but I
mean it's not a trick if you can afford
it you know
but then I can't deal with these other
ones man these ones that just sell the
[ __ ] straight across because first of
all I gotta like you
if there's no chemistry with you my guy
won't rise you know what I'm saying it's
like um and then and then most of them
got a bad bad side manner you know what
I'm saying I had girls approach me and
and proposition me and I'm like hey that
sounds good and we get there now she's
mad that she has to do this
and she's all pissed off like me I mean
you approached me with this I mean if
you was a waiter a waitress or something
you wouldn't even get a tip right now
you got to be nice if this is your
occupation your bedside manner sucks you
know what I mean they like really pissed
and then they don't want to do nothing
your body language says no but their
mouths keep saying yeah but you know you
can't get into them they don't want to
touch nothing they don't want to suck
nothing they don't want to get you going
I figured that the guys that really get
off on these prostitutes they got to be
already jacking off in the car you know
what I'm saying so by the time they meet
one of these chicks it's just a put it
in release thing they've already built
the thing up in their head there's no
way they can sit and talk with somebody
and get aroused no matter how fine she
is on the spot like that and just and
just want to just put it in quick type
[ __ ] it doesn't work like that for me
and they're all business and I'm like Hi
how are you what's your name I gotta
know if I like you in a person so I'm
always having problems in that in that
department is the fact that these girls
are
available any night of the week
uh does that get in the way of perhaps a
real relationship with a woman that does
not work the street yeah
it does because you because um I don't
have time for it because um my schedule
my work schedule I work middle of the
nights and stuff you know and
construction sites I sit there all night
so yeah sometimes I can look up and take
one with me but when I happen to know
you know what I'm saying
it's not no wondering and once you put
the money in your hand they're not
giving it back
and they'll they'll renege on the on the
whole sex act
you know what I'm saying so I didn't get
I think I worked all the time because
somehow when I'm being dictated you know
what I'm saying I gotta follow my guy
you know what I'm saying
and he knows better than I do what's
going to happen in advance he'll start
leaving already but wait a minute man I
just paid 100 dollars a room don't go
you already know she's full of [ __ ]
let me talk to her first man we got a
hundred dollars invested on this and I
just gave her some money he knows ain't
nothing honey
I just can't listen
I go out like this every day man they
get me all the time
I'm used to it
so out of uh five times I meet one I
might [ __ ] twice
if that out of five
three you're gonna give me or am I
[ __ ] your [ __ ] and I might fall
asleep and they're gonna rob me
and he's the ones I know these are ones
I even know you know what I'm saying
well I catch one doing doing bad I'm
leaving somewhere and I stop and turn
around and go spend 50 bucks on a room
or something for me and stuff and uh buy
them some drugs or whatever it is they
want and I still want to get that [ __ ]
or they fall asleep or something I can't
just [ __ ] somebody in their sleep it's
just not my get down you know what I'm
saying you got to at least lift your
legs up and say come on Harry that's my
wife used to do I'd be messing with her
all night you know what I'm saying come
on baby come on baby and she finally
just rolled over and said hurry up you
know what I'm saying but you got to give
me the go-ahead or I won't touch you I'm
going to be a gentleman to the end to
the end of the line you know what I'm
saying I want some response you know I
want you to sleep all through they said
he wants to [ __ ] somebody that's laying
there dead you know I don't get it I'll
do that I'm 57 now what have you learned
about women from your your uh since my
youth well since yeah it's 57 years
um um um
it's not about who you love it's about
who loves you
my dad used to say that to me and I
finally understood it
it ain't about who you love it's about
who loves you
so stop paying attention to the ones
that you love that ain't giving you time
up worth the damn and pay attention to
the ones that's looking for you
but that ain't the one we want we want
that one that run over there you know
what I'm saying we like the thrill of
the chase if you give it to me too quick
I don't know how to respond to that oh
my God wait a minute I ain't asking no
[ __ ] yet you're not trying to give it
to me you know what I'm saying and then
it just throws me off set you know I
mean I'm trying to get to know somebody
and it seems like um
my only options are these readily
available hoes on Figaroa are drugs a
part of your life yes used to be used to
be I've cut down on all that stuff man
had a few health problems and stuff I
was doing crack I've done Crystal now I
just smoke a little weed I don't even
drink anymore
smoke a little pot and that's legal now
so it's all good A lot of the girls you
pick up will be using now oh yeah
yeah definitely right and in fact um
when I was selling this stuff they were
my main customers
and many customers were the hookers
especially the ones that didn't like to
have a pimp their pimp was the drug you
know what I'm saying
uh-huh I got what you want baby what's
your biggest regret in your life now
biggest regret is um
getting caught by my wife
is it horrible getting caught I'm not
saying I would regret doing it because I
always got to go out and do it I'm a guy
you know I'm saying I say baby when I'm
doing this today I'm not making love to
these women you know what I'm saying I'm
jacking off in them you know what I'm
saying ain't no different than me doing
this in the bathroom watching watching a
video or something you know a book in my
hand and I mean it's nothing personal
with you it's totally different you know
what I mean I want to kiss you I want to
hug you I want to cuddle with you I want
to lay with you you don't want to suck
something most of these chicks don't
even take all their clothes off you know
what I mean you won't even get a titty
flash you know they're gonna have this
on and they'll pull that down and they
want to do it in the car I'm way too big
dude I got a truck and I can't even do
it in the truck I tried you know what
I'm saying so I got to go get a room I
like closed doors and now all these old
tents and stuff I don't know how they
get naked in the tent you know I'm
saying I just knowing I'm gonna get
robbed soon I take my pants down or
either and then you know running water
in there and then there ain't no door
that you can lock you know what I'm
saying so that worries me so I can't do
the gutter thing
we could do it right here no we can't no
we can't it doesn't work like that for
me I will never be comfortable trying to
get it looking around
somebody coming you know what I mean
or they got somebody set you up as soon
as you get around the corners some guy
runs up that's my girl next thing you
know yeah huh yeah I mean Rob
yeah that's that's one of the games that
they play yeah yeah so yeah they got
moves right some of them actually
admitted
yeah they actually got moves man they
are taught to get the money as fast as
they can and get out of there
sex or no sex
it's less sex is best
that's because they're just all about
the money
so I'm saying these guys that are really
doing this on a regular basis man they
can't there can't possibly be ready to
[ __ ] instantly like that it's impossible
you can't you got to you have to build
that up unless you just riding around
jacking off and you're ready and then
you finally get a a girl inside and then
you know what I mean as soon as you
touch them other things it's a wrap you
know what I'm saying you can get it in
you got slick leg do real love real good
and stuff you know what I'm saying you
tricked you out your money and you skied
it on your own leg or some stupid [ __ ]
it's impossible but they are out there
and they are beautiful man I see some of
them so young man it's ridiculous I like
so in your whole life in your whole
goal-oriented life this was all you
could come up with at 17 18 years old
and be out here selling your ass
really you didn't have any other goals
you want to be a nurse or anything like
that I mean babies man I mean and
super fine like TV fine you know what
I'm saying so I just like riding around
looking at them I know they ain't gonna
give me no play because I'm a black guy
you got my pimp or don't [ __ ] with black
guys you know dates because they [ __ ]
too [ __ ] long and I do you know what
I'm saying I'm gonna get my money's
worth sometimes I don't even get in that
I just [ __ ] for an hour or two and
say [ __ ] it until I run out of gas
all right cash thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem man thank
you so much luck out there all right
thanks